personne ne touche cette balle jusqu'à ce que nous
découvrions ce que c'est et j'avais besoin de merde dans
ce sens, j'en ai eu assez j'ai définitivement de la
merde cinq cents super
montages mec ce n'est pas un âne d'une
fille de douze ans c'est phénoménal oh
mon dieu toi  gars jumeaux ouais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
peur j'ai ce scénario dans mon
esprit femme au foyer asiatique sexy seule la nuit
mieux appeler la montre et ensuite obtenir cet
[ __ ] mais cette femme elle me suce les couilles
je suis aussi intéressé par ce qui
m'arrive je ne '  Je ne veux pas paraître enfantin mais je
dois faire pipi tu devrais manger plus tôt Je suis
désolé tu sais que le liquide entre dans les liquides
doit sortir mais manque les paiements oh
super c'est bon non Bob oh mon Dieu nous
allons sans frapper avec un boeuf et
avec le stop and go stop it made happy
stop it euh-huh fais en sorte que ça se produise
tue tu serais un détenteur de livre oh
il y a maman je reçois un journal dans des lumières super brillantes
mon frère vient de briller une
lampe de poche sur mon visage je chierais mon
pantalon  mon logo est génial mon logo est minuscule
moi comme c'est méchant  s salut tigre signifie ailes de tigre
et avions qu'est-ce que je combine ciel
sérénité optimisme attaque tu es fou
beaucoup de ce gars était bon
Kristen orgie qui se passe localement hey
on y va j'aurai ton nom en temps voulu